>>Female Presenter: Without further ado, I'd
like to introduce David Crane from Google
Ventures.
[applause]
>>DAVID CRANE: Good late morning/ early afternoon.
Thanks to everybody for coming to Google and
convening together around what's guaranteed
to be a super exciting screening of a very,
very important documentary.
I think we're brought together today because
something called the "Global Employee Resource
Group Summit" has been taking place for the
last couple days.
I'm reading my cue notes here, as you can
tell.
This is an important activity, though.
This is a group of Googlers that have come
together to focus attention and time on planning,
leadership development, and relationship-building,
all organized around diversity.
I've been at Google a dozen years and one
of the sources of great personal pride is
watching this diversity initiative first be
dreamed up and then actually built, scaled,
and executed.
And I'm so proud of what my colleagues do
in all areas of diversity, particularly in
this one area that we're spending some time
paying attention to today.
This documentary--this is, I think, a multi-year
project at CNN.
We're in the fourth year.
This particular program, as you will soon
see, I had a small participation role.
I spent some time being able to see a number
of very inspired, very talented entrepreneurs
that spent a summer at Silicon Valley chasing
their dreams and trying to understand whether
they could turn those dreams into businesses.
It was a pleasure to see them, to interact
with them, to see their first pitches, their
first public articulations of what they're
doing.
And in just a few minutes, you're gonna see
the output of an interesting project that
CNN has invested in to chronicle this journey,
to illustrate some of their challenges, some
of their successes.
As soon as the documentary is over, there
will be a very interesting panel discussion
led by a few folks that are sitting up here.
So please stick around.
Without further ado, let's roll that video.
Thank you.
[applause]
>>Michelle Thornton: So, we expect you're
gonna tell everyone to watch, right?
November 13th?
OK.
Great.
I'm Michelle Thornton.
I work for CNN.
I get to hang out with Soledad sometimes.
I try not to stand too close 'cause she always
tries to look kinda cute.
[laughter]
And I have, or at least, my job at CNN is
to monetize content like this because it's
important for two reasons.
One, of course, funding.
That's what this conversation is about.
But advertisers wanna have this conversation
with you guys.
You guys are consumers.
And they wanna let you know they respect content
like this.
The other reason I wanna do it--let me tell
you--I never get to wear blue jeans at CNN,
OK?
[laughter]
So, thank you so much for hosting this.
When LaFawn Bailey calls, we say yes.
We don't ask what it is.
But in all seriousness, we don't see conversations
like this, right?
We see comedy and we see other genres.
But we don't see real conversations about
real serious topics.
So, we want you to support and watch and tweet
and Google+ [laughter] this type of content.
So, I have the privilege today to introduce
all of the panelists.
I was told by my good friend Soledad to tell
you that this wasn't the ending.
So, there is a cliffhanger.
So you'll get to see, hopefully, some good
news.
Our moderator, Navarrow, is the--it says here
CTO.
Don't you guys hate that?
He's the Chief Technology Officer, in case
someone didn't know what that meant.
>>Navarrow: This is the one place they would
actually know what that meant.
>>Michelle Thornton: Oh, OK.
All right.
Good.
[laughter]
See?
I kinda fit in.
I kinda don't.
And then, of course, Soledad, who by the way,
is our new morning anchor starting in January.
Yay.
[applause]
With that being said, we cannot let her get
away from telling stories like this.
So, we're going to see her around these docs,
but she will also be the face from 7 to 9.
So, we're very proud of her.
Second up is Chris Genteel.
Chris?
All right.
He said he might sing a song for us.
[applause]
Or maybe not.
He's said the Black Eyed Peas were here yesterday.
So how come we didn't get to come yesterday?
What's really going on?
And then, as you saw on the screen, is Ang--.
Here goes Angela.
Angela.
[applause]
So, we can't show a doc and not have a conversation.
They're gonna talk and then they're gonna
allow you guys to ask some questions.
So, enjoy.
>>Navarrow: So, how's everybody doing?
>>Audience: Good.
>>Navarrow: It's a little different from the
last time I sat in this chair, as you can
see on the doc.
So first, I'm sorry, I had to run over there
and charge up my iPhone.
It won't keep a battery.
If you guys can suggest another platform I
might switch to afterwards.
[laughter] Let me know.
We can talk after.
So this is gonna be really informal.
We're gonna have some conversation up here.
I want you guys to be involved.
I'm hoping you have a lot of questions.
And we'll make it engaging.
But first, I wanna start with Soledad.
For people who may not know about the "Black
in America" series, maybe you can talk about
why you and CNN feel it's important to tell
these stories and what the effect has been.
>>Soledad : I'll have to start at the very
beginning then.
The "Black in America" series started 2007,
when we started working on a six-hour, three-part
documentary, which really started with the
anniversary--the 40th anniversary, of the
assassination of Dr. King.
And I was asked by the head of CNN Worldwide,
"Do you think there would be an interest in
a look at the assassination of Dr. King and
also African Americans--'Black in America'?"
So with that, we took the ball and started
running with it.
And we did a two-hour documentary on the assassination
of Dr. King, and then, two more days of two-hour
docs with our first "Black in America."
And it was wildly successful.
Some people loved it.
Some people hated it.
But what it did do is spur a lot of conversation
about stories that clearly were not being
told.
And in fact, probably the biggest compliment
that I got when people would stand up at anything
else I was doing and say, "When are you doing
'Asian in America'?
How about 'Caribbean in America'?"
My own mother said, "Oh, so no Afro-Cubans
in your little documentary.
[laughter]
Interesting.
Those are your own people you let down."
So, it was just really successful.
And I think it was a moment that people felt--.
For me, we saw that we could do these really
interesting stories about people whose stories
really didn't get told and you could also
win.
It was wildly successful ratings-wise.
It was just a big win across the board and
it didn't have to be stuck in a, "Well, we're
doing this programming because it's a good
thing to do.
And if no one watches it, that's OK because
we've done our good deed on the diversity
front."
It was like, "Wow.
We can win with this."
And then after that, we started doing "Latino
in America."
And then we created the unit, "In America,"
in order to tell a bunch of stories.
We did "Gay in America," "Muslim in America,"
"Education in America," "Working in America"--looking
at coal miners.
And again, we were just really successful.
So, out of that, the "Black in America" series,
we kept thinking about, "Well, what are the
stories you could do?"
The first one was really a survey.
The third one was a look at--.
The second one was another survey and we decided
then to take a look in the third one in a
single topic, which was a church and a pastor
and what that church was doing at a very tough
time economically.
And then, this one, of course, was--.
So, we try to connect what's happening in
the story-- a single subject story--to what's
also happening in the world at that moment.
So, how do you make it relevant news-wise,
but also compelling, interesting?
'Cause a documentary is a story that's unfolding
in real-time, or something is at risk, or
you're cheering for people, you're rooting
for people and there's something happening.
That's our definition of how we do documentaries.
And so, we really think on this one in particular,
you end up touching a nerve when people start
arguing about the parts of your documentary,
right?
Because it means you've really hit something
relevant that people are willing to go and
shout about their perspective.
And I love, ultimately, for all of our documentaries--it's
about a conversation.
So, if we're able to get people to stand up
and yell on one side or the other, or talk--hopefully--in
a more calm tone about one side or the other
to start a conversation, then I think we've
been really successful.
>>Navarrow: So, I'm sure we can all think
of thousand topics we'd want them to cover.
Can you talk about why you chose this topic?
>>Soledad: You know, again, I think for documentaries--any
documentary--it's "are the characters great?"
We went out.
Jason Samuels, our producer who's in New York
today, but who's been literally emailing me
constantly, "Tell me.
What's the blow by blow?
What are they laughing at?
What do the people think?”
So he came out and really met with Angela.
And at first, over the phone, and then met
all the people in the house.
Because the truth is, are they good characters?
We call them characters?
Are they interesting?
Do you care about them?
Do you want to see them win or lose or struggle?
If you do not care, it will be a terrible
documentary.
And then, it was clearly in a house--eight
people in a three-bedroom house--was already
going to provide some issues in terms of just
people close together in a small space who
have a lot going on and who were stressed.
As Pius pointed out in the doc, no drinking,
no hot tubs.
So, it certainly wasn't going to the "The
Real World" or anything.
But it certainly, I thought, was a way to
explore an issue that was relevant.
And then again, "Does race matter?" is a very
interesting question to me.
I think of our "Black in America's" really,
ultimately, can be boiled down to that question.
Does race matter?
[Soledad laughs]
>>Navarrow: Sign off on the crowd.
So, Angela.
Can you tell us a little bit about what made
you decide to create The NewMe Accelerator?
>>Angela: I'll try not to get too lengthy,
but--.
So, as you saw, I had a site called BlackWhite
2 point 0, and I started that about four years
ago.
And then, last year in 2010, I had a conference
called the "NewMe Conference."
And we invited entrepreneurs and people in
government and also people in private equity.
And it was a day and a half.
And we basically closed it out with brainstorming--what
it would really take for minority entrepreneurs
to be successful in the technology industry.
And one of those things was an accelerator,
but the idea just seemed so huge, so--it was
just in the back of my head someplace.
Wayne, I've known for a while actually online,
how I meet most of my friends.
[chuckles] But he had the idea for a start-up
house.
So, it brought really this residential component
to what an accelerator is.
And then also, when I went back and looked
at my notes from the conference, it really
helped satisfy a lot of the barriers that
people said existed.
So, it's really expensive to live out here.
People felt like they were disconnected and
couldn't actually come out here and just relocate.
So, that was one thing that really helped
lower that barrier.
And then people just felt like they didn't
have a network at all.
And that really hindered their ability for
their companies to be successful.
So, giving them mentorship, a network, and
just real--not a curriculum--but just knowledge
from other people's experiences.
It just turned into an accelerator.
>>Navarrow: So, Chris.
You were here at the welcoming site.
You were sitting in the audience.
Maybe, can you give us some of your impressions
that day of that event?
>>CHRIS: Sure.
You've got entrepreneurs who have never been
in that position before, maybe being somewhat
on the spot.
And getting access to minds like yours and
David Crane.
And getting at that real, live--an old mentor
of mine used to call it--the "oh, shit" moment.
[laughter]
This is the real moment.
And you could see from that moment on, over
the course of the summer, and I think the
piece captured it really well, just elevating
the stakes of the whole thing--making it really
real.
We were proud to see that be at the beginning,
of seeing that.
And then, seeing that transformation.
And also knowing that raising that game and
having that success was within their reach
because now, we're here.
We're part of the mix in Silicon Valley.
>>Navarrow: So, Angela.
We know that that was a challenging day for
all the entrepreneurs.
Can you talk a little bit about some of the
other challenges you faced that you maybe
didn't expect to face when you guys started
this program in the Valley?
>>Angela: Yeah.
There are a lot of very little reasons, very
little things, that I just like--just different
situations.
I really just expected, I guess, people to
be a little bit more like me and just really
focus in on the work and not other issues,
and really commit to that for nine weeks.
But there were other things that came up around
transportation, [chuckles] around what type
of food people wanted to eat, and just other
little things like that that I didn't even
think of at all.
>>Navarrow: So how important was it to do
it here, in Silicon Valley?
>>Angela: Oh, it was hugely important.
Mainly because this is the epicenter for technologies.
So, it really had to be here.
Not only that, there aren't really many minorities
in the--well, African Americans specifically--area.
So, for us to do it in New York or Atlanta,
it would not have had the same impact at all.
>>Navarrow: Soledad, after meeting the characters
and getting in-depth in their stories, can
you talk about maybe who surprised you or
who stood out to you in terms of their stories,
the things you learned about them?
>>Soledad : You know, when I meet people,
again, 'cause my job is--I'm a storyteller,
right?
So, my job is to sit in on this and say, "So,
what's the best way to tell this story?"
And not just to a room of people who are in
technology, but to a room of people who know
nothing about technology, or their only technology
is their mobile device and that's it.
And how do we make that story live and be
relevant and interesting?
So, it really was digging into people's stories.
For me, what struck me about Angela was all
that she was juggling.
That here's a woman who's a mom, a single
mom of three kids, who she has left behind
at home while she is working on this big idea.
And she's got this company she's also trying
to launch at the same time.
And she has all these little things in the
Accelerator that she has to manage that have
popped up--some big little things and some
little little things.
And every time I'd see Angela, she was pacing.
On the phone and pacing.
When I asked the question--.
The first time I saw Angela, we drove up and
Jason said, "Oh yeah.
That's Angela.
The house is down there, but that's Angela."
And there was a woman in sweats, pacing up
and down.
So I'm like, "That's the woman running the
house?
She's pacing up and down."
So, we really wanted to capture that incredible
pressure that is on someone who both really,
personally wants to make a difference, but
also really personally wants to be successful,
too.
And as a person who has before, many times
in her life, people have low expectations
of what she can achieve and she's always said,
"Well, low expectations doesn't mean I'm not
gonna achieve."
So, we wanted to get that in there, too.
I love Anthony and I think when I watch the
doc, I always feel that my love of Anthony
comes out because he's the youngest.
He's 25.
And he told me--we didn't really have the
ability to put it in the documentary and I
tried 8000 different ways--but the thing he
said to me, which broke my heart and made
me love him more, he said, "You know--."
He started really playing around with video
games and really just being in technology
when he was about 7th grade he said.
And he just loved computers.
He loved technology.
But as he went through school, there was no
one to capture that and channel him into,
"Well, if you love that, you should be doing
this.
Well, if you love that, you could be doing
this."
And so, he was sort of, by his guidance counselor,
who sounds like a jerk, kind of forced in
a direction, "Well, just go to community college
and do this and do that."
And not really put on a program where he could
take what he's passionate about clearly, and
combine that with a fabulous job at the end.
And he said, "You know, if me, today, had
been in front of me as a 7th grader, my life
would be totally different."
Honestly, it just broke my heart.
It just, because he, and he said it in a way--.
And the way I've said it is so inarticulate
compared to how Anthony said it.
He said, "I would be a totally different person
if the person I am today stood in front of
a classroom full of me, young men, who love
games and who love that kind of technology,
and I said, 'Be an engineer.
It matters because you can create those games
that you love.'"
And so, this is his reason for trying to be
part of the Accelerator.
He feels really connected to all those other
kids who look like him in Newark, New Jersey.
And we will put some more clips online just
'cause I love that so much.
And obviously, we have an hour, so it's not
that you have an unlimited amount of space.
And think that was true for a lot of the founders,
right?
There's this personal part of it, too, that
makes you want to succeed.
'Cause it's not just about you.
If you succeed, that's great 'cause everyone
wants to be a gajillionaire.
But also, you can change the game for other
people.
You could literally open up everybody's--you
know the pattern matching, right?
You can change the pattern, but you could
also inspire people.
You could be literally a role model and someone
could say, "I wanna be Anthony Frasier.
You saw Anthony Frasier?
He just sold his company for a billion dollars.
I wanna be Anthony Frasier."
That, to me, would be an incredibly great
indication of the needle moving for this industry.
>Navarrow: Chris, we've talked about some
of the challenges in trying to connect minorities
with technology.
Maybe you can talk about why Google decided
to partner with the NewMe Accelerator?
And also about just Google's efforts around
diversity in general.
>>CHRIS: Sure.
I'm on our Diversity Inclusion team.
And there's literally probably 20 or so people
in this audience who do participate in our
efforts to help black-owned businesses get
online and be successful, using our tools
and just using the power of the internet to
get their business online and get in front
of customers.
And of course, we're a technology business.
And we've seen the immense profit, immense
growth in technology.
And we don't see those businesses reflected
in our customer base, and we don't see them
reflected in the Valley.
When we met Angela, who I think is a role
model for a lot the Googlers here, someone
who is successful, young, black, female, in
tech--and she came to Google and spoke to,
I think, maybe 30 or so black Googlers in
a room that didn't really fit that many, [chuckles]
and then some by video conference, who video
conferenced in to see her--it was inspiring.
And it was obvious that we needed to find
ways to partner with her, to help us change
what we saw as a problem in Silicon Valley.
So, NewMe, Angela and I, were sitting on stage
for a panel at the Black Enterprise Conference
and it was May 23rd, or something, of this
year.
And she said, "I think I wanna do this Accelerator."
And we were here on June 16th making that
happen.
It was incredible, the speed with which she
moved to that, which is something that at
Google, we know something about, which is
moving really quickly.
And when you see someone like that, who just
so embodied the spirit of that tech and quick
and "let's get it done," you know that you
have to partner.
>>Soledad : Can I add just one quick thing
to that?
And I think for the documentary, what we loved
about Angela is, again, the room that I'm
talking to for our doc is not a room full
of technologists.
I think Angela is inspiring to everyone, right?
Somebody who says against all odds, "Well,
I have this thing.
And I think I wanna do it.
And I think I can do it.
And if I can just get some support together,
I can do it.
And even if I'm driven a little bit crazy
every step of the way--'cause that's how things
go--I'm still gonna try to be successful."
I think that's incredibly inspirational to
me, who I hand off my technology when I have
a problem.
Here, someone fix that for me.
Thank you.
[giggles] So, I think that my goal in this
doc as well, is to highlight people who are
inspirational.
And the only way to be inspirational is to
go through something on-screen so people see
what you're dealing with, and the challenges,
and to see how you come out the other side.
>>Navarrow: So, Angela.
Everyone in this room can appreciate execution.
We know the value is all about execution and
we've heard several cases now that you moved
at a rapid pace.
How does it feel seeing your idea come from
that idea on the Black Enterprise panel to
fully-executed, first launch class?
>>Angela: It feels great.
And actually, every time I see the doc, it
takes me really back to the moments of the
summer.
And it's like, I get all happy and stuff inside.
And I can't wait for the next cycles and everything.
So, it feels great.
And I'm really excited to hear what everyone
else thinks about it.
And then once it airs on November 13th, just
to see what really, the world, thinks about
it, too.
>>Navarrow: So, as you can see from the doc,
I had a lot of opinions.
So, if you categorize me as the angry uncle
of NewMe, I'd have to categorize Mitch Kapor
as the Godfather of NewMe.
So, Mitch, I wanna throw a question to you.
You were deeply involved in the process.
Maybe tell everybody your impressions about
the program, the group, and Angela, and just
the process that happened largely in your
facility.
>>Mitch Kapor: I've been involved in helping
a number of Accelerators, Y Combinator and
others, and heard about NewMe.
And because it intersected thematically with
other things that Frieda, my wife and I, are
doing up in San Francisco with the Level Playing
Field Institute and my foundation, I immediately
said, "Great.
I'll do something here."
When I met Angela and the entrepreneurs early
in the cycle, I was really impressed.
I was impressed with the seriousness.
I was impressed with the dedication and I
thought a number of the ideas that they were
working on were pretty good ideas.
So, I doubled down and said, "All right.
I'll get more involved.
I'll make some time.
I want to do some mentoring--take people through
the process, share my experience."
And then, we made our office space available
to hold the demo day in.
And I'm hoping and believing that with Angela
being out here now, the goal of establishing
NewMe as an ongoing, recurring--not a one-time
thing--but something that can regularly be
a way to facilitating increased participation
for African Americans in Silicon Valley.
We're helping with that.
We think that's incredibly important.
Ultimately, we'd like to see it not just in
Silicon Valley, but elsewhere.
It's just that important.
I mean, the stakes are huge.
Not just for the individuals, but as I said
in the clip in the movie, economically, if
you look at demographics in the US, by 2040,
we're gonna be a majority/minority country.
And if we're not developing every single talented
individual to do what they can, we're not
gonna be competitive as an economy.
So, the other thing to keep in mind though,
is like any other population of entrepreneurs.
The history, background, skills, quality of
ideas, persistence--there's variation among
individuals.
And it's been very interesting for me to see,
not only during the nine weeks, but subsequently.
You can begin to see who is really more likely
to succeed as the group sorts itself out.
But overall, this is just such a necessary,
such a gratifying thing.
And I'm so pleased that CNN and Soledad and
Jason and the whole team put all of the effort
into this because it is gonna shine a light
on this issue and as we say, start conversations
which need to happen.
Silicon Valley has a very difficult time talking
about race.
Anybody who follows the twittersphere and
the blogosphere has seen that play itself
out in the past week.
And I'm hoping that those conversations will
improve and people will find it easier to
talk about real and important things--not
necessarily to get everybody to agree, but
to talk about one more elephant in the room.
>>Navarrow: So, Soledad.
>>Soledad : Yes.
>>Navarrow: Mitch talked about it a little
bit.
Can you talk a little about what the effect
the "Black in America" docs have on raising
the conversation on the given topic?
I think we've all seen over just the last
week, the doc hasn't even aired yet and there's
been a lot of activity on Twitter.
But I actually only saw it on Google+.
[laughter]
So, I don't know where anyone else saw it.
Was it anywhere else?
I'm not sure.
[laughter]
But maybe talk about how the documentaries
have raised conversations on this.
How do you see that this documentary may raise
that conversation?
>>Soledad : I think the documentaries have
been successful across a number of categories.
And in terms of spawning conversations, they've
been really successful.
And I figured that after the first one when
people would stop me in the airport--any airport,
anywhere--and say, "You wanna know 'Black
in America?'
My life is 'Black in America.'
Put me on TV."
[laughter]
Like, 25 times a day.
And people who loved it or hated it would
say, "I hated what you did.
I should be the next 'Black in America.'"
Or, "I loved what you did.
And it was really clear to me that there were
just all these stories that were not getting
any kind of airtime, and certainly not in
a long form way, but just all stories.
I mean, really, not just for African Americans,
but I think for Latinos, for Asians, for Native
Americans, who get literally no coverage at
all.
And I thought, really what the "Black in America"
series has done, I think, in terms of shining
a light on "you can tell stories on diverse
populations."
And by "diverse populations," I mean women
who were rescue workers at Ground Zero.
And you can do really well.
Again, it doesn't have to be often, I think,
in TV news when we tip our hat to diversity,
it's that "here you go, here it's Women's
Month and here's a story on this.
And now it's Latino Heritage and here's a
story on this.
“The world is changing.
The audience is changing.
And guess what.
Everybody is interested in these conversations.
You can win and you can do them well, so you
can do quality work that wins awards, that
is well done, that people wanna run home and
watch and be part of and be part of the conversation.
So, for a journalist, I look at that as winning
across the board.
And that was really critical.
>>Michelle Thornton: Can you just add real
quick, because I think it's changed people's
lives through pairing and funding and money?
>>Soledad : Oh, yeah.
That's true.
There's no question.
I mean, I end up keeping in touch very much.
Like, Angela, in 20 years, you and I will
still be talking because I--.
>>Michelle Thornton: You'll be famous.
>>Soledad : And I'll be trying to get a seat
to do an interview with you.
>>Michelle Thornton: Right.
>>Soledad : What we found is that what we
did for our second "Black in America"--.
The first "Black in America," Roland Fryer,
Professor at Harvard.
He just won a Genius Grant and so we obviously
keep in touch with the work that he's doing
in education.
Steve Perry from the second "Black in America,"
who has now expanded his school, which was
a six through twelve.
And now, he's opened an elementary school.
And he's a contributor on the education space
on CNN.
We just continually, I think, are able to
change lives.
For me personally, my husband and I started
a foundation after Hurricane Katrina.
But after the first "Black in America," one
of the young women that we interviewed was
a girl named Nya Buckley and she was getting
an HIV test.
And afterwards, I said to her--this beautiful,
smart, sharp girl.
I said to her, "Why are you here?
Did you go to college?"
And she said, "I have a baby.
I have no one to handle the daycare."
So I said, "OK."
After the doc aired, "I'll pay for your daycare
if you go to college."
And now, she's a junior at Lehman College.
And we have a bunch of other people--Maria
Arquetto, who we did in Latino in America
2, who swam across the Rio Grande to get to
America and ended up in detention and then
was able to get a visa and now is on her path
to citizenship.
She's starting community college in a couple
months.
So, I think we were able to really connect
people to those stories because people were
rooting and caring about those very characters.
So, I think we have.
I mean, it sounds so dramatic to say we've
changed lives, but I do think when you open
things up to a conversation, you certainly
allow for the ability for lives to change.
>>CHRIS: And Soledad, all those people who
stop you in the airport, we want to remind
you that they can all be "Black and Latino
in America" on YouTube every day.
[laughter]
So, park that one back here.
We're gonna talk about that later.
[clapping]
>>Soledad : Trademark, "Black in America,"
by the way.
[laughter]
>>CHRIS: All right.
>>Soledad: Our lawyers can talk.
We're good.
>>Navarrow: So, Angela.
Maybe we can talk a little bit about, you
know, Soledad mentioned there's only so much
they can show in an hour, right?
So, what are some of the things that happened
that were key experiences for you and the
group that didn't make it to the doc that
you really want people to know and understand?
>>Angela: Really, like the sleepless nights.
So, I think you get a little bit of that,
but we also did--we did work a lot.
But we really did a lot of other stuff.
And I think part of this whole being black
in technology conversation, a part of that
is mentorship.
So, another thing that we did that didn't
make it to the doc is we actually went--well,
not me--but a couple of the founders who have
STEM degrees actually went to UC Berkeley,
to speak with some children from a program
called SMASH, that's put on by the Level Playing
Field Institute.
And that was a really, really rewarding experience
because you could really see it making a connection
in these kid's lives.
And them coming up even to me-- I was just
there because the founders were there--asking,
"Can I email you?
I have questions."
I mean, it was just a really, really good
experience to have in life.
So, it was tons of experiences like that.
And really, I think you guys got our dynamic
in the house, but really the friendships that
were developed out of this.
Like, I saw Pius and Becky last night.
And the people I've been seeing, I've been--.
I did move here, but I've been heads-down
for the past month, so a lot of the people
that I'm seeing, I haven't seen them since
the last day of the program.
And just rekindling those friendships and
those relationships--that was huge.
And I think that's really what makes the program
different from other Incubators and Accelerators
is the residential part and these relationships
that end up developing.
>>Navarrow: Chris, maybe you can talk a little
bit about--.
We understand that there's just a lack of
knowledge.
And I think the key part of Angela bringing
these people in the house is that they were
exposed to a lot of things that otherwise
they might not have had knowledge of.
Maybe you can talk a little bit about--.
I know you guys have programs like Google
Accelerate.
How do we leverage those and get those into
the community in a big way to make sure that
more people can even know about Angela's program?
>>Chris: That's what we're working on.
I think we have tools that are, for the most
part, free, that can empower the millions
of, the two and half million black businesses
that are out there.
And a lot of folks just don't know about it.
So, a couple of things that we're doing is
we're working with some very specific partners,
like the National Supplier Diversity Network,
or Black Enterprise Magazine, to try to tell
the story very loudly about how the web empowers
business, how the web empowers growth.
We're also working on some other programs
to make sure that people are using Google
in their business, that they're using our
Gmail apps and docs apps and things like that.
And when we get in front of individual folks
and when we give them these products, it lights
them up.
We're giving away free websites to every business
in America through a program that we've been
piloting and getting out.
In Detroit two weeks ago, we had a thousand
different entrepreneurs come downtown.
It was a majority minority crowd, which you
would think would be the case if you were
in downtown Detroit.
But I'll tell you, it's not the case unless
you bring in the right partners, unless you
bring in folks like Angela and Hajj Flemings,
one of the entrepreneurs from gokit, who's
one of our partners in Detroit.
Unless you bring those folks in and they get
the word out to their communities.
Unless you get into the faith community.
Unless you get into the folks who really are
saying, "This is something that can help your
business."
So, we're doing things like that across the
country to raise that awareness, get those
tools out in front of them and empower them
to create huge businesses online.
>>Navarrow: Just a thought, Chris, there's
a little company called Interactive One and
we service maybe 85 percent of the African
American market.
If you're looking for new partners, I could
probably put you in touch with some.
>>Chris: All right.
If you know anyone--.
>>Navarrow: You know what?
Let's talk after.
I think I can make that call.
>>Chris: Thanks.
>>Navarrow: So, I want to open it up to questions,
but before we do that, I wanna give Angela
the opportunity to talk to people about what's
in store for the future of the NewMe Accelerator.
>>Angela: Wow.
So, all my big ideas.
So of course, I want it to be everywhere.
But we're taking baby steps.
One of the really great things that I'm excited
to finally be able to tell people today is
Google is actually gonna be the presenting
sponsor for all of 2012.
And so what that really means for the program
is that we'll be based in Mountain View again,
but we'll also be working out of the space
here.
And so, that’s--.
[clapping]
>>Navarrow: That's clappable, right?
>>Soledad : Now I have to go into a re-edit.
>>Angela: Yeah, so lots of re-editing for
you guys, [chuckles] but yeah.
So that's really exciting.
Also, some other stuff that I'm working on
is like, yes, there's the Accelerator, which
will still stay in the same shape that's it's
in.
But some other things that I also want to
do is have a NewMe community, which that goes
into other submarkets--maybe like Atlanta,
Chicago, and so on and so forth.
And those are really like community-driven
where it's not the full blown program, but
it's a smaller version of the program where
we can pull from communities that are under-served.
So, we are working with some partners on that.
And so hopefully, I can tell you guys more
about that soon, too.
>>Navarrow: So, great.
Any questions from the group?
I think we have a microphone that's ready
to travel if you raise your hand.
>>MALE #1: Hi, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
My name's Isaiah.
I've been working here at Google for about
a year and a half now.
One thing that I thought was really interesting
when watching the documentary was one of the
characters.
He had success at getting funding before and
had some failures.
And so for me, that highlighted a bigger problem
that once minorities actually get here in
this space and got the funding, it seems like
even more people are not achieving the success
that they would like to.
So, I just wanted to hear your thoughts on
what's being done to address--.
Or, what some of the bigger challenges are
in staying here once you've gotten your idea
adopted and gotten the funding you needed
to and what can be done, or what we can do
to provide resources to help people maintain
their success?
>>Angela: Sure.
Well, I think, I mean, entrepreneurship, it's--.
The Accelerator focuses on something that's
very early-stage, but it really is a journey
and it's a longer life cycle.
So, for Hank, part of the story that wasn't
told is when he was working on Clickradio,
that wasn’t the first dot com bust.
So yes, he raised 40 million dollars, but
his business suffered like a lot of other
businesses.
So, in terms of how do we make sure that companies
stay successful, honestly I think all of this
is really just a huge learning opportunity.
So, we might not know right now because there
really aren't that many success stories.
But over the course of years, we should be
able to get some really good data on what
we can do to make sure that people become
successful, they have exits, they can also
then reinvest--hopefully in some minority
businesses--and then we can really start to
have a pure life cycle to creating really
great companies.
>>FEMALE #2: Hi.
My name is Cynthia and I--.
>>Soledad : OK.
Hold it close to your mouth like that.
Thank you.
>>FEMALE #2: So, I thought the post screen
conversation was at least as interesting as
the film itself.
There are a couple of furious blog posts floating
around the internet that were really interesting.
I was wondering if you ever considered maybe
doing a Google+ Hangout with Arrington and
Vic Gundotra and like, Ron Conway, and you're
just getting them all in the same room together
'cause it seemed like they all had different
experiences and they all disagreed with each
other.
It would be really interesting to hear all
of them interact, rather than--.
>>Soledad : Sounds like you're inviting me
to be in a Google+ Hangout.
The answer is yes.
I'd love to.
And anyone who wants to email Mr. Arrington,
who's blocked me, is welcome to.
[laughter]
I'm kidding.
In all seriousness, I am more than happy to
be part of that conversation.
And I think you're right.
I think what that whole Twitter debate showed
me was that there was anger.
And everybody was stuck in their spots.
And really, a lot of what everybody was saying
was actually about a lack of representation.
So maybe we could move the conversation for
being stuck down here, and move it up here.
I really think if you look through every single
person's post--all of it--there was a sense
of, "Well, here's what, here's part of the
issue.
And here's what could be done."
Right?
That's the area of the concentric circles
of where we all agree.
So, maybe have a conversation about that.
So, yeah.
I fully support that.
I'd be more than happy to be part of that.
>>Navarrow: Isn't the premise of Google Hangouts
that everyone has to show up?
I think we'd have a hard time getting Arrington
to show up.
>>Soledad : You never know.
You never know.
I wouldn't assume that.
Maybe.
[mild laughter]
>>FEMALE #3: Except people at Google docs.
>>Navarrow: Right.
>>Soledad : Way in the back?
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
>>Navarrow: Nope.
Mic.
>>FEMALE #4: Hi.
My name is Nava.
I had this question and it's open to any of
the panelists.
But historically, black-owned businesses weren't
really emerging about maybe in the 90s or
so.
And according to the US Census, between 2007,
2006 and 2007, black-owned businesses increased
by about 60 percent.
That's huge.
And granted, those black-owned businesses
were small.
The fact that, culturally speaking, you had
a father who either owned an auto repair shop
or a mom who owned her own business in the
health care industries said a lot about how
they were passing on inheritance.
And traditionally, allowing their families
to know about why it is important to have
your own business.
So, do you think the digital divide has also
created an issue between both the industries
and the technologies sector and also, the
African American community?
And I just wanna know what your insights are
on that.
>>Soledad : That's a really interesting question
and I think that that statistic I found very,
very interesting, right?
This huge--.
Blacks completely outscore on entrepreneurship,
way above everybody else.
And so, why do we not see that translate in
technology?
It's not like, "Well, you know, it's not really
culturally relevant for the African American."
No, that's not true.
We far over index in that--in entrepreneurship.
And so, I'm not sure the answer to that.
And I do think that that digital divide is
part of the answer.
>>Chris: Yeah.
And the other part of that stat, 60 percent
growth over a five-year period--2002 to 2007--however,
in terms of the size of those businesses,
far smaller than the average size.
So, we know there's traditionally been a lack
of access to capital.
Something that you mentioned, Nava, was we
haven't seen the generational businesses that
have helped majority businesses succeed.
Something that's really fascinating to us
in our work with Google customers, is we start
to see those black entrepreneurs who are older.
Those "sons and daughters of" really taking
over and leading those businesses' growth
into the online space.
So, that's a promising trend that I think
we can really capitalize on in terms of helping
those businesses not only exceed in terms
of the number of businesses out there, but
in terms of the wealth that they're bringing
back into the community as well.
>>Navarrow: So, I wanna jump in on that just
because this topic in particular is something
I'm really passionate about.
So, I believe we have--and I've said it a
lot--a perception problem, right?
The challenge we have is that there are a
lot of African American businesses that they
don't have the understanding and knowledge
of the technology opportunities that are out
there and that their barriers are so low.
You gave a great example.
You said a bakery.
You said barber shops.
None of them know how technology could help
them grow and scale their business.
So, I think there's opportunities there.
So when you look at the digital divide, really
it's about literacy today more than it's about
access.
The numbers show you that African Americans
over index on cellular devices.
But if you go and ask them how many of them
know about Square, where they can plug it
in with no merchant account and immediately
take credit card purchases, the answer will
be slim to none.
So I think the challenge is, how do we bridge
that gap?
How do we make that connection that they understand?
I mean, Chris talked about any business having
a website for free.
I can guarantee you that that's not made it
into the African American community.
And I think programs like Angela's will not
only raise the level of entrepreneurship--'cause
yes, we all wanna be Facebook, we all wanna
be Google--but there's levels below that that
are incredibly successful and people can support
their families and have a good living and
create jobs that we have to communicate.
So I think that's the big challenge.
>>FEMALE #5: Hi.
Yolanda Mangelini.
So, question probably for Angela, or any of
you can also do this.
So, if I think about one of the challenges
for a black entrepreneur is having access
to the networks, right?
I think I saw someone in the documentary mention
that.
At Google, we believe in doing things that
scale.
And you started with a handful of entrepreneurs.
How do you scale that?
I think about--.
I'm a graduate of the Stanford Business School
and my best friend there is black.
He worked at Merrill Lynch.
He went to Stanford.
He worked at McKinsey.
We were a year behind Jeff Skoll, who's a
founder of eBay.
So he had access to all these networks.
He started his own business and it failed.
And I think about someone like that, who had
access to the networks.
How do you scale what you do?
>>Angela: Yeah, I think--.
Chris and I talk about this a lot.
But I think one of the key ways to scaling
something like this is really changing the
format a little bit so it might look a little
bit different.
It might not look like the Accelerator proper,
but it might take on more of--.
I guess the idea that I have in my head is
almost like a continuing education course.
And then also something that's accessible
online, something that can also possibly be
self-guided.
And then, something that also pulls from networks
of mentors that are highly qualified that
these individuals can tap into.
So, that's really the bigger idea that I have.
Like, how do you scale something like this
that doesn't necessarily need to be something
that's brick and mortar?
You know what I mean?
>>FEMALE #6: So, often--just a quick observation--which
is often there's problems that are out there
that always feel so daunting.
How are we gonna fix education in America?
How are we gonna get more people who are not
included, in this case, into the economy?
And I always--.
I'm Megan.
I lead New Business Development here at Google,
and we get to work with engineers when we're
starting new things.
So, I have a lot of experience with the beginning
in entrepreneurs.
I also got to do the acquisitions of Google
Earth and Maps and Picasa and other things.
So, I've worked with very talented entrepreneurs.
And one of my observations is on the daunting
problems.
Two key things throughout history always are
the things that end up solving them.
And they come in two forms.
One is in storytelling, which is somebody
figures out how to tell us the story of what's
happening in a way that opens our minds to
know about something and often includes not
only the problem, but some of the solutions
so we can begin to pile onto it.
And so, Soledad, thank you for "Black in America"
and for focusing on things because it raises
our consciousness in a way that is significant.
And adding in people who are doing great things,
like Angela, let's us pile on Chris and others.
And so, that's the second part of it, which
is whether it's a social, political, or economic
invention that's gonna really make actual
change, it always comes from a person or a
small group.
It's a Margaret Mead quote.
It's always true.
I mean, the founding of our own country comes
from these entrepreneurs.
We know them: Thomas, Benjamin, Abigail, John.
And they were funded by the French VC's. [laughter]
And so, when I do development work, I'm like,
"We're the French.
We're the French.
Where is the talent?
Who are we gonna help?
Who are we gonna fund to help in other countries?"
And I think in our own country.
So, I just want to acknowledge that this is
the only way out of the problem.
The singular only way is to help the entrepreneurs
do their thing.
It's not about some kind of aid or whatever.
It's about finding the top talent, as Mitch
talks about, and getting behind them and helping
them.
And in Silicon Valley, having raised 30 million
dollars here for the company that I ran in
Web 1.0, it is totally an apprentice, journeyman,
master thing.
And we all know that who have gone through
this.
And it's all about the network.
And I've always felt like, as we started the
BOLD program, we finally broke in to the talent
networks of the undergraduate populations,
started pulling them to Google and to Silicon
Valley.
We need to do that with people mid-career--break
into the talent networks.
And in this particular case, you have figured
out a way to break into the talent networks
on the entrepreneurial side.
And we in Silicon Valley now have to step
up and help you help those guys and then bring
this to all the other cities and help this
country as well as the Greek economic crisis.
'Cause the only way out of this stuff is through
entrepreneurships.
So, thank you.
>>Angela: That's a great point.
Thanks for making it.
[applause]
>>Navarrow: When your questions have 20 great
points, [laughter] we just don't know where
to jump in.
It's like, great point one, great point two,
great point three.
>>MALE #7: I had a, I think its economic issue,
follow on question kind of along.
When you see folks who start a lot of the
start-ups in Silicon Valley, they tend to
be computer geeks.
I think Arrington, I think the tech crunch
guy mentioned that.
So, do you have any plans to get that pipeline
into your programs so that you don't get,
not so much so entrepreneurs, but people who
are maybe specialists from a technology perspective?
>>Angela: Yeah--.
>>MALE #7: It seems to be the profile that
works.
>>Angela: Sure.
About half of the founders in the program
were actually developers.
But what I think is really interesting, on
the panel last night, Pius had a really great
point.
He mentioned that he thinks the pipeline issue
is overplayed a little bit.
Like, yes, STEM education is important and
everything, but we all know here in Silicon
Valley and in the technology industry, you
can teach yourself how to code.
That's one of the beautiful things about it.
And Crissan, he didn't have a computer science
degree at all, but he was coding.
I mean, he built his product.
So, when we look at applicants, the program
is very product-driven.
So, we look at products.
Like, yes, we look at the entrepreneurs and
everything, but we also really look at products.
But I think--.
I have a fine arts degree.
You know what I mean?
So, I'm not just looking at people who have
STEM degrees at all.
So, I really just want good people who are
driven to be successful and will do what they
need to do.
Those people might be developers.
Those people might be entrepreneurs with a
development team.
>>Navarrow: Just, so really quickly.
I think that's an important point to bring
up.
Because one of the things that Arrington said
that does ring true, one of the challenges
entrepreneurs have is if you aren't technical,
you have to find a technical co-founder.
And that's not a racial thing.
That's an entrepreneurial thing.
The challenge that makes it uniquely African
American is that there are so few of us who
take up those technology fields, which goes
back to the perception problem.
So, how can Google fix that?
I guarantee you, if you--and Mitch can probably
attest to this through his programs--if you
bring a busload of kids in here one day from
Oakland and tell them that in order to work
here, they have to learn how to program.
The next day, the Oakland library will be
empty.
Because there's a light at the end of the
tunnel.
The reason why Angela's program is so groundbreaking
is 'cause there's visual examples of the possibility.
So, what we have to do is continually show
examples.
And in this room, I've seen black Googlers
stand up en masse and they ask questions.
Those are example that people say, "You know
what?
It's really not that hard."
And to my young woman in the back who gave
us 30 good points that I can't even remember
them all, she made the point that once you
do that, you've triggered that change.
You've made that exception.
That's what we have to figure out to do, which
goes back to Soledad telling this story.
>>Mitch Kapor: So on that point, something
that companies in the Valley can do is to
continue to intensify their efforts to recognize
that talent comes in many different kinds
of packages.
'Cause it's easy to do pattern matchings as
VC and it's easy to do pattern matching as
an employer.
You look for the right degree from the right
school and so on.
And that's all well and good, but there are
a lot of incredibly qualified people who just
look different and they've had a much longer
distance travel.
But if you're willing to look, you can see
they can do the job right now.
And so the face of Silicon Valley could be
different than it is because there is some
supply coming through the pipeline that is
not landing the jobs that they could be landing.
And so, that's a call to action for employers
right now.
[applause]
>>Navarrow: That's clappable.
Thank you, Mitch.
>>FEMALE #8: Hi.
I'm from Women at Google in London and just
came for the Diversity Summit.
I think what you've done is just absolutely
phenomenal.
But I can see how it seems there's less ladies
in the scheme.
Was that a particular challenge?
Was it a focus?
And going forward, is it something you're
gonna particularly look at is how to get more
ladies involved in this program?
>>Angela: So, the program, even though I think
we've been dubbed like, the Black Accelerator,
the program is really for underrepresented
minorities in technology.
So, that is African Americans, but that's
also women and that's also Latinos.
One thing that I think you guys probably weren't
able to see is like, yes, I was a woman and
Tiffany was a woman and we were in the house.
But Crissan's co-founder was also a woman.
Pius, Becky, she's a woman.
So, we did have a good amount of women involved.
Could there have been more?
Yes.
I'm excited to look at applicants for 2012,
so it'll be interesting to see what the makeup
ends up being in the future.
>>FEMALE #8: Right.
Thanks.
>>Navarrow: We're gonna take about three more
questions.
That's puts the pressure on everybody.
>>FEMALE #9: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
My name is Sabrina Williams and according
to the documentary, I guess I'm an oddity.
So, I'm a black female programmer.
[applause]
>>Navarrow: Clappable again, please.
>>FEMALE #9: And actually, I never thought
it was that big of a deal until I got here.
[laughter]
But I was actually, as a follow on question
to that, did you or Tiffany run into any extra
problems, like being the double-whammy black
and female in the course of the program?
>>Angela: For me, I actually felt like people
didn't listen to me a lot.
And I'm short.
My voice is soft.
And I mean, I don't know, but I definitely
feel like people didn't listen to me enough,
but luckily I have people like Mitch and Navarrow
backing me up a lot throughout the summer.
So, that's something that I actually didn't
expect, especially because I have a pretty
strong personality.
>>MALE #10: I'm gonna steal one of the last
questions.
Steve Strong, I wanted to ask you, get back
to actually the video and say we saw the journey
from the beginning to the end and I know you
only had an hour.
But I want some insight into what were the
"aha" moments you really transformed the team
from that first presentation to the end?
They showed some snippets, but were there
a few key events that really transformed the
team?
>>Angela: Sure.
So, part of what you saw was Navarrow's dinner
in the first week.
That was really jarring and people were like,
"Oh, we gotta do better."
So, that was one point.
Then we had a midway point at BlueRun Ventures
and people really still weren't up to par.
From then, we didn't really have a hack-a-thon,
but we had a design-a-thon, and that was really
to get the visual, the UI part of everyone's
products on par.
After that, I think Mitch spent like his whole
Saturday, the week before demo day, and really
gave us the extra time, effort, and feedback
that was needed to make sure that people were
on point because in reality, we only had like,
a day and a half to actually practice in the
facility.
So, those were all key "aha" moments.
You could definitely tell after each one of
those events that people got better and better
after that.
>>MALE #11: I guess I'm the last question.
>>Soledad : I think we're going to do 2.
Go ahead.
>>MALE #11: OK.
My name is Curtis Pope.
I was one of the new start-ups this summer.
I can totally attest to what Angela's talking
about.
It was a very aggressive schedule and all
the different things were very instrumental
in helping us to be successful.
My question is more to Angela.
You mentioned the community’s part.
Is part of those communities, is part of that
communities part teaching people how to code?
Do you think that that's--?
>>Angela: So, the curriculum for that is not
set yet.
So, I'm not sure.
I know that I wanna have at least four different
types of programs that can rotate and they'll
probably be about four to six weeks long.
But I'm not sure exactly if it'll be teaching
someone how to code.
I mean, I know we'll definitely have to rely
on a lot of partners also to help.
So, I'm not sure exactly what that will entail
yet.
>>Soledad : Marvin, why don't we give you
the last question?
>>MALE #12: Hi.
I'm Marvin Avilez.
I've been an entrepreneur for about 20 years
now.
Grew up in the Bay Area, right here.
Macromedia, Oracle, Apple, a variety of other
companies and--.
>>Navarrow: And now you're just showing off.
[laughter]
>>MALE #12: My question to you is, I was once
told and I didn't realize it, when I was about
23, that I was a minority in the business.
And I was shocked and never thought of it
that way.
And so, I ask you now, with the house and
saying, "We're gonna look at more of the minority
group, or the female group, or the under-served
group," are you attracting attention that
might be a little bit on the negative side
because we're labeling it that way?
Or, are you just another great Incubator like,
Y Combinator, or NYU Poly-Tech in New York
City?
'Cause that's how I see it.
I see that you're taking--.
You're a start-up of start-ups.
And that's what was so exciting to see in
the one house, right?
Well, that's gonna grow next year and now
it's at Google.
To me, that's how I see it.
So, I'm curious.
Have you guys confronted that issue or has
that come up at all?
>>Angela: Yeah.
I think we're a really great program, first
and foremost.
And that's my goal is just to be a really
great program.
But there is a problem and we don't see women
a lot.
We don't see African Americans and we don't
see Latinos a lot.
So really, it's a really great program, but
it's also a solution to a problem that some
people choose to ignore.
And so that's really all I see it as.
>>Soledad : And I was gonna add one thing,
too.
We get a similar question for news stories.
"Well, why do the black story?
Aren't you really dividing?
We're really all Americans and we all should
be under the same--.
Why do Latinos?
You're separating people out."
And I'll give you the same answer that a woman
gave on a panel for our documentary called
"Beyond Bravery: The Women of Ground Zero."
And someone said that very thing.
"You know, women were no more brave than the
men.
Why do you make it seem like the women are
special?"
And she said, "Well you know, take a guess
at how many dogs of Ground Zero stories were
done."
Many.
[chuckles] And that women stories also just
deserve to be told.
That sometimes, we go out of our way--and
not really realize it--we're only telling
one story.
That we were selecting only that one story
and what we're trying to do is just open it
up and tell more of those stories.
So yes, do the German Shepherds of Ground
Zero.
Do the Golden Retrievers of Ground Zero. [laughter]
I am not making that up.
Those are stories that were done.
[laughter]
And then also do the women of Ground Zero
so that you have a more accurate picture of
what the environment looks like.
But only then, you're really telling the full
story.
To me, it's not meant to be divisive.
It is really meant to just paint a more full
picture.
>>Navarrow: And just one the Accelerator piece,
I think the one thing you think about is anything
that's birthed that's uniquely African American
is birthed out of lack of access in that area,
right?
And I think the challenge we need to realize
is just as those Accelerators exist, but they
haven't been accepting African Americans.
And I'm not gonna speak for them about why
that's the case.
We just know it's not happening.
So, Angela's program was birthed out of a
need.
And anytime something's birthed out of a need
that people may not agree with, there's gonna
be negatives.
But the positives far outweigh the negatives.
And I think you all guys know here that there's
a process in the Valley.
And I think what Angela's program does is
indoctrinate a new demographic to that process
that feeds the need that Mitch talked about
in diverse and new ideas coming to the ecosystem.
So, I think that's important.
So, we're gonna wrap up.
I'm gonna ask you guys three things.
First, on behalf of CNN, please watch the
documentary November 13th at 8 PM.
[applause]
>>Soledad : Tell a million of your closest
friends.
>>Navarrow: Tell a million of your closest
friends and we're at Google, so we know you
have a million closest friends.
The hash tag is pound sign black in America,
so please--I know you guys don't do this--but
tweet it as well as Google+ it and everything
else to let everybody know.
The second thing is I'm gonna make an ask
for Angela.
There are a lot of great minority entrepreneurs
and engineers in this room.
Please connect with her.
She'd love to have you guys come through the
programs and connect with the future classes
of the NewMe Accelerator.
And lastly, please give me a hand in giving
this panel a round of applause.
Thank you guys.
[applause]